I'm looking for a sense right right when
he
touches I'm I'm moving here
okay
not and he stops you see how he stops so
right when he touches sometimes it's a
little bit of yielding but it's
definitely not getting out of the way
now he's going to
stop so a little yielding but it's
moving him moving him moving him moving
him moving him see moving him moving
him so you have to be in his body
even getting him to touch me over here
it's more than it's Body
Mind touch over here let then stay there
and I'll let go of the EO hand let see
the other hand is doing it
too so always moving moving moving
moving keep moving you see
that
not and then he's stop stops and
then and you pull him
around different UK will do different
challenges okay they'll do different
challenges so I brought him in with the
yield and he's just going to stiffen up
he just stiffens up you see and now if
we've changed directions he's going to
stop all right so just for his
correction uh when you feel that that's
your Yin space to come in do you see
there's your attack do you understand
but he didn't do that he pushed back he
pushed back he pushed back so he pushes
back that's what keeps him
moving so in his body in his body in his
body it doesn't matter what your hands
are doing doesn't matter what your hands
are doing he has to keep
moving so my hands are doing different
things different
things again don't confuse it with I'm
getting out of the
way I did I did yield meaning he's
pushing this way I did
yield but I I have his body that's
what's
yielding I'm
yielding yielding in his body always in
his
body body means his whole body okay look
at the
difference you
see so you feel right from the start
right look how your pelvises can't go
down where you wanted it to go I'm going
to let go I'm going to ask you to let go
and let you finish cesa okay let go
and's where she wanted to be
so in in in move her whole body move her
whole body her whole body is moving
whole body is moov move her whole body
body body and I go this way her whole
body
mov you'll feel right from the start the
body's
moving
different stop start you see
that
already connected already
connected I'll take
this so again uh she hasn't learned how
to lock her Center it doesn't mean I
can't find her center from where she's
at so if I don't if I go this way I'm
out of her body
so I won't go that way we're going to
move her whole body her whole body even
if she wants to lay down there I'll move
it over
here in in she wants to lay here oh
we're going to go this way
though
[Music]
take this one you know now she wants to
go there I'm going to match her downward
energy here and start to bring it around
around that energy there and you'll feel
that want you feel here's this goes
off right there's your will that's I can
move around move
around in your
body in your
body
over
here where does he want to go he wants
to go there in that energy that goes
there
put your hand like you go in there
little back that's what I use to move
his
body do it
again put your hand right
there feel this
difference you go back again so I'm here
you're going to twist out put your hand
like you want twist out
this like
in his b turn your head the other
way try to do that okay
go stopped now on try it
again stop on a little
[Music]
better
stay off on
okay
better let's switch R switch rolls again
you're still ning go let's go in the
body in the
body up off on okay here I'll show you
first fine you're in his
body so he can start pulling he can pull
you see you pulling pulling it doesn't
matter you're in this
body okay so I'm trying to show you that
I'm not just getting out of his way I
don't call getting out he pushes on me
and I move out of the way that's not
what I'm doing there's an adhesion the
adhesion is moving
okay so he's here even though I'm in his
grip I'm not pulling on his grip I'm not
trying to do joint manipulations just
at contact he grips I'm in his body
right from there and we move his
body okay now here's the thing am I not
still he's touching me okay but what
you're doing is you're going off you
just go
off can I still not keep that adhesion
and move
him you see you get it okay so uh
home it's your transition just goes off
and then it'll go back into his body
when you're pushing but you want to be
in in his
body in his
body on your should you got here and
your transition should stay in his body
you see making him move right there's
going to be a point if I stop and I try
to go for the elbow's going to stop but
the other hand is touching him so if we
let go here the other hand is going to
be in his body too the other hand is
going to move
him so I all up I get here on the other
hand is moving him do you see the two
are moving
him as opposed to same thing here then
it goes off till I get in position
and then it goes back on again so you're
missing the Ian on the yin cycle okay so
boom
yawn then you're going to have it on the
yin cycle see how it keeps moving him
moving him moving him moving him moving
him is still Yin till it gets where I
want it to be and then it'll go
[Music]
y can't go like that it's off he's
following me
okay I'm using it using
it B using
it okay try it
again feel for it to go off because then
you drop the feeling you lost the
feeling and iy is a feeling that you
maintain go